the Best Exotic Marigold O'Dell it's a
lovely hotel not all hotel experiences
are as good now we do have some
first-hand knowledge of this because
Sharon Morgan where were you a
chambermaid I was a chambermaid
in I think it was the Imperial Hotel or
something that signs like that was my
first job after leaving school and so I
spent a summer making beds and scrubbing
human excrement out of toilet bowls it's
weird because I don't think I I don't
think there was a single toilet bowl
that wasn't kind of decorated and
because when people go on holiday
they're just like I deserve to not clean
my own crap out of my - Annabelle is
that what holiday says to you
I use the bowl
miron I'm not an animal
you sometimes don't bother picking your
knickers off the ground if you're in a
hotel because you think someone's gonna
come along and pick up my knickers and
but you know it was exciting I always
thought that you know I might meet
someone you know in a sort of chamber
maybe may be an attractive mom you know
you know I'm sure you saw that movie
with JLo didn't you
because den de gens you have quite
exacting well not acting but you're very
specific you are very regular with your
hotel habits regular
don't you when you in London don't you
always stay in the same room I do I do
well no not the same room the same hotel
but this is where you've got your own
dressing-gown they have given me a
dressing-gown which had jadi on it which
I was very very proud of but then I had
a kind of sneaky feeling that maybe if
Johnny Depp stayed there he did they the
guy from JD Sports DJ D on it yes -
right now it's yours
well here's the thing thanks to the
World Wide Web anyone can now review a
hotel right and so we've got these are
actual online reviews of actual
experiences people have in hotels so his
first one I got to the hotel to check in
and on my way to the elevator I slid
right into a pile of diarrhea that was
near the elevator it goes up my knees at
my arm as well as my luggage the hotel
staff did not help me in any shape or
form and told me to watch where I was
going how is it my fault there is poop
on the floor in the first place my room
was horrible it's not like poop as well
I was disgusted never again what I like
about this is one of two people found
that review helpful
Oh person no that's not help stop having
looked at these I think one's the
minimum you probably were no star what's
up next
now please take notice that this view me
and my husband and two kids went to
these apartments for a week and I must
say never again we arrived at 5 a.m. and
we're introduced by member of staff is
met I said you've got passports we sat
down on my daughter 13 sore to people on
the sofa next to the bar making love
whilst being videoed by the chef
[Applause]
they weren't doing a good job good
service still got two stars location was
excellent
next up do not stay in this absolute
dump Hotel I use the term hotel very
loosely I kind of a strongly enough how
disgusting this place is blood scent
headboards not really been up since
world war the first one windows it won't
close no hot water broken furniture
dirty utensils broken light fittings and
short poo and the kettle
[Laughter]
[Applause]
David let's see the next one I wish we
hadn't gone oh now this is a weird one I
don't know whether it's an actual
spelling mistake or whether it's also
correct but it makes the review very
confusing indeed I wish we hadn't gone
the meal was ruined by midgets
everywhere and we were sitting inside we
even move tables near the back wall that
table did we woke up the following
morning covered in bites and very itchy
[Laughter]
well anyway we were given the keys to
the wrong room and walked into the room
to find a naked African gentleman
washing his genitals in the sea
are you whispering
[Applause]
[Laughter]
when deaf girl writes a book this is in
it says damn do detest washing his
genital next one this is the final one
this is nice I like this person this
person is just a sensible person they've
been around the block because they're
all the reviews about this is just
someone who kind of understands the
world and sees the positive for the
price I paid to stay on New York's Upper
West Side I'm surprised it wasn't worse
the room smelled like armpits and you as
a phil' but there weren't any creepy
crawlies and I find the staff to be most
gracious and helpful I could have done
without the blood-stained mattress and
the actual chunk of poop on my bedspread
I didn't expect the Hilton Oh pinch I
would stay there again this is how good
it was they were quite happy to give me
new bed spreads when I reported the poo
[Applause]
sometimes fill the audience when you
sing price tag now life is that money
money song ok
judi dench unbuckles her pants and on
her bum as you say yes JD loves HW he
said I put your name on my ass